[Musique]
il n'y a point de mot ni de crayon ni de
couleur pour vous peindre audessus d'un
toit d'ardoise violette brodé de mousse
rousse le ciel de mon pays tel qu'il
resplendissait sur mon enfance ce pays
qu'évoque Colette le pays de son enfance
c'est la puisé dans le département de
Lyonne au confin de la Bourgogne deor du
Morvent la classe où chaque matin se
rend la petite Christine et celle de dru
les belles
fontaines l'école a toujours tenu ici
une place particulière
paulbert un des fondateurs de
l'enseignement public est originaire du
département dans chacun de ces villages
surtout les plus pauvres d'entre eux
sont sortis depuis un siècle des
générations d'instituteur et
d'institutrices tous passionnément
attachés leur métier l'enfant
parti mettrez une
virgule accompagné de son
chien tout près de dru à Ry où longtemps
enseigné habite madame
champrou
virgule dépêche-toi un peu
toi
faire sa promenade habituelle
elle est âgée de 78 ans et elle donne
chaque jour des leçons de rattrapage aux
enfants du
village
habituel qu'est-ce que tu a dit pour
écrire
habituel sememble à quel
mot à toi habitude tu ne sais pas écrire
habitude il manque une lettre écrit en
marche tu n'as pas compris
toi manque une lettre
habitude écris en M s'il te
plaît
comment tu écris
habituel qu'est-ce que c'est habituel en
grammaire et
toi un
adjectif qualif é pu de quoi promenade
alors et toi
habituelle t c'est ça mon ami
habituéissement je t'en prie
etpress tuelle
oui
monsieur je sors d'une famille
excessivement pauvre mon père était
maçon et ma mère avait suffisamment de
travail avec les SEP enfants qu'elle a
eu c'est grâce à ma mère à son travail
que nous tous nous sommes arrivés à être
instituteur et
institutrice sur cet enfant nous sommes
restés cinq et les CIN sont devenus sont
devenus tous instituteurs et
institutrices mariés avec des
instituteurs et des institutrice et
comment s'est déroulé votre enfance
madame misérablement j'ai travailler
nous travaillons très jeunes ma mère
savait nous faire travailler dès l'âge
de 5 6 ans j'ai gardé les oies
o et c'était un travail pénible de
garder les oies c'est fort
désagréable et non seulement je devais
garder les oies mais je devais
rapportter des glanes de blé
c'est-à-dire un bouquet de d'épit de
blé que ma mère comme récompense nous
permettait de
voir battre ces glanes il faut vous dire
que mon père battait somblé
lui-même il se levait à 2h du
matin battait jusqu'à 5h à 5h il partait
dans le villages
environnant pour faire sa journée de
maçon pendant ce temps ma mère
s'occupait de quelques vaches qui nous
permettaiit
d'améliorer notre vie
ve très simple puisque très souvent nous
mangions pomme de terre omelette de la
viande deux fois par
an au jour de l'an et à la Saint-Michel
qui était la fête du village et comment
passez-vous vos soirées de peties fille
là les soirées étaient délicieuses parce
que mon père lisait faisait la lecture à
haute voix et lisait surtout les
misérables et des livres de su je crois
les vieux livres il y avait toujours
quelques voisin qui venaent écouter mon
père qui lisait très bien et je me
rappelle que je partageais les sanglot
de mon père quand on arrivait au passage
de Cosette et pendant ce temps ma mère
filait au roué pour faire drap et
chemise
comm madame champrou la plupart des
maîtres d'école de cette génération ont
connu une dure enfance
villageoise ils sont allés tout petit au
champ aux vaches ils ont été ramassés
l'ER beau lapin l'exercice du métier
l'instituteur a représenté pour eux et
leur famille le début de l'ascension
sociale et pour y parvenir
avant de se retrouver derrière la chair
du maître d'école le petit paysan
appliqué et bien dououé a dû d'abord
affronter un Rud d'apprentissage qui a
modelé toute sa jeunesse à Tingi dans la
petite maison où il s'est retiré et que
seule la rue sépare de l'école où il a
presque toute sa vie enseigné nous avons
rencontré Monsieur lunud c'est avec une
sorte gravité attendrie qu'il évoque ces
très vieux souvenirs monsieur lunau
vous avez quel âge 92 ans vous êtes né à
qu vous êtes né à quelle date 23 juillet
79 et vous êtes entré à l'École normale
à quelle époque
en
97 à la rentrée d'octobre 1er octobre
probablement c'était à ha
à nous avions un directeur qui était
somme pour l'époque moderne
euh qui succédait à un directeur qui
était une sorte de garde chourme et qui
considérait les élèves comme des
enfants notre directeur nous considérait
comme des euh messieurs comme des hommes
d'ailleurs il nous appelait messieurs
les élèves
maître quelques années plus tard madame
Lenoir se trouvait de son côté à l'École
normale des jeunes filles d'cè dans la
même promotion que Madame champou la
tutelle qui pesait sur toutes deux
semble avoir été particulièrement
austère ça n'était pas une cécure à
l'École normale est-ce que vous avez des
souvenirs justement de cette période de
l'École Normale oui monsieur d'ailleurs
pour la nourriture nous avions la soupe
le matin avec un morceau de pain et
quelle soupe à midi un bout de viande un
morceau de viande et puis des légumes
plus ou moins bien préparés et la le
soir la traditionnelle soupe avec
quelques légumes ou surtout du riz qui
n'était même pas épluché
ensuite nous avions des professeurs très
gentils mais ça n'était que des vieilles
filles nous avions une directrice
mademoiselle
foucré qui avait une phobie
d'normaliiens que nous appelions
des pinguins parce qu'ils avaient un
vêtement noir avec deux pans et des
cololles de celluloïde très haut et
quand nous sortions en rang de par deux
et que la directrice nous accompagnait
aussitôt qu'on apercevait un normalien
il fallait baisser l'ombrelle ou le
parapluie pour ne pas qu'on regarde les
les normaliens l'École normale elle
mmême se composé d'une grande salle
d'études d'un d'une sorte de gymnase d'
prù qui faisit où nous faisions la
gymnastique d'un amphi où il y avait un
squelette et puis alors la cour par
elle-même puis d'autres salles forcément
et la cour par elle-même qui était
entourée par des galeries nous
l'appelions la fusse aux ours nous avons
gardé mademoiselle Foucret pendant 2 ans
et elle a été remplacée par Mademoiselle
odoule et quelle conception
s'efforceit-on de vous donner de votre
métier
d'institutrice vous savez une conception
un peu dure il fallait beaucoup beaucoup
travailler à l'école normale nous nous
levions à 6h30 hiver comme été et nous
nous couchions à 8h30 9h mais on nous
donnait toujours cette intuition qu'il
fallait travailler beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup travailler c'était juste
c'était juste l'abnégation l'esprit de
sacrifice la discipline du travail il
fallait bien en leset les
apprendre ce sont ces vertus
essentielles enseigné dans les tristes
salles des écoles normales que le jeune
instituteur et la jeune institutrice
seront appelés à pratiquer dès leur
début dans la carrière après quoi votre
premier poste d'instituteur proprement
dit vous l'avez eu je l'ai eu mon
premier poste à rNY en
1900 au retour du régiment en 1901 au
mois de novembre vous gagnez com combien
à l'époque je gagnais c'était un
traitement dérisoire en principe nous
avions 900 francs par an
et on nous faisait la première retenue
pour la retraite les 4 premiers mois si
bien que les 4 premiers mois nous
touchions 58 francs 16 centimes c'était
c'était très
peu c'était même
lamentable et vos premiers rapports avec
les enfants comment est-ce que ça s'est
passé vous étiez content d'enseigner ah
au début j'étais très content
d'enseigner parce que j'aimais l'enfance
j'aimis l'enfant par
lui-même d'ailleurs ça continue encore à
l'heure actuelle parce que je n'ai pas
d'enfant à moi mais j'en ai constamment
ici alors j'aimis l'enfance c'est
pourquoi je me suis adapté tout de suite
à ces enfantsl et alors je suis tombé
dans à rogi dans une localité où il y
avait quantité d'enfants dans ma classe
déficients
anormaux
même j'en avais même un qui était
complètement
idiot et je suis
parvenu par les méthodes que j'employais
la méthode que j'employais à lui
apprendre à lire
parmi les anciens élèves de Monsieur
lunau le Maire de Tingi monsieur
guillaumo monsieur luno lui a autrefois
bien souvent tiré l'oreille il est
aujourd'hui sénateur de Lyonne monsieur
le sénateur je crois que vous avez été
l'élève de Monsieur lunud oui monsieur
j'étais l'école de Monsieur à l'école de
Monsieur lunud depuis l'âge de 7 ans
jusqu'à 12 ans c'est lui qui m'aené au
Certificat en
1925 je crois c'est dans cette écoleù
trou c'est dans cette école que Monsieur
luno a exercé euh 1 an je crois avant la
guerre 1418 et il est revenu de 1919
jusqu'à 1934 année où il était mis en
retraite comment était-il comme
instituteur c'était un instituteur
remarquable il a fait une génération de
d'élèves qui vraiment ont suivi un
chemin dans la vie euh grâce à lui grâce
à à c un éducateur parfait il était très
sévère j'ai eu quelque fois les oreilles
tirées hein je pense que je les ai eu
moins souvent que je le méritais nous
nous l'aimions profondément nous le
craignons c'est certain enfin nous avons
un profond respect pour lui monsieur
lunau pour nous c'était le grand
bonhomme je vous dis nous avions un très
très grand respect pour lui comme
instituteur vous étiez
sévère c'est-à-dire que
j'étais un mare sévère et souple
je nétais
pas mais pourtant le sénateur nous a dit
que parfois vous lui tiriez l'oreille ah
oui
maisoup pas so ou
l'autres à ce momentl c'était pas plus
permis qu'aujourd'hui n pas mais on se
permettait c tout de même s histoire les
parents dis même vous faites
bien que
maintenant plus du tout autour de
l'école qu'ont connu dans leur début
monsieur Nino madame champrou et Madame
Lenoir se sont déroulé pourtant des
combats
acharnés les grandes lois scolaires de
1881 et de
1882 ont achevé de constituer
l'enseignement primaire en service
public l'instituteur est désormais un
fonctionnaire payé par l'État
l'enseignement qu'il dispense au nom de
cet état est gratuit mais aussi laïque
c'està-dire amputé de toute instruction
religieuse fidèle aux traditions et aux
enseignements de l'Église l'opinion
catholique
s'insurge en s'emparant de l'âme et de
l'intelligence des enfants
l'enseignement public ne va-t-il pas
être l'instrument d'une
déchristianisation
générale à propos de l'école deux Fran
s'affrontent et se déchirent
l'instituteur et le prêtre apparaissent
au regarde beaucoup comme des
adversaires à jamais
irréductibles alors c'était l'époque des
grandes Lutes scolaires est-ce que vous
en avez conservé des souvenirs encore
vivants oh très vivants oui pour une
bonne raison c'est que nous avons
totalement vécu notre jeunesse dans ce
bain là en somme alors il y avait
l'école privée et qui était l'ancienne
école qui avait toujours existé et
l'école laïque et voilà l'école laïque
on ne voulait pas en entendre parler il
y avac que les vieux républicains qui
envoyaient leurs enfants à l'école
laïque alors de ce fait on était très
mal vu dans le pays et quand il arrive
ait que à la sortie de l'école les deux
les deux écoles se rejoignaient vers
l'église accompagné chacune de leur par
leur maîtresse alors vous savez les mots
étaient pas toujours très très aima
comment vous appelz--on et bien l'école
laïque on avait demandé à ce que les
enfants de l'assistance aillent à
l'école laïque alors on nous disait
méchantment ah ell vont à l'école des
bâtardes alors pensez que nous ça ne
nous plaisait pas du tout et si c'était
dans l'hiver où il y avait de la neige
et ben ellees étaaient sérieusement elle
était sérieusement servie avec les
boules de neige c'était un véritable Pug
ah oui c' un combat et voyez c'est une
chose voyez une division qui vraiment a
resté tout le temps même étant jeune
fille nous n'étions pas vraiment amis on
n' pas fait d'amis chacun restait dans
son clan et c'est tout et peut-être même
dans la vie on pourrait dire que ça
s'est continué et c'était terrible ça
parce que c'était toute une jeunesse qui
était divisée pour pour une question
d'école chacun des deux camps accuse
l'autre de fanatisme et de sectarisme et
sans doute ces accusations ne sont-elles
pas toujours
injustifiées y a-t-il un dieu une âme
néant quels sont nos ennemis les curés
très bien mon garçon vous avez droit à
une
bourse la lutte paraît cependant avoir
pris des aspects sensiblement différents
sur la diversité des situations
ai la bonne volonté des hommes est-ce
que les parents des enfants connaissent
vos idées avancé sur le plan politique
vous n'z jamais difficulté avec J
d'Illes je suis venu ici il y avait
famill
religieus tout le
reste contre l'Église d'ailles quand je
suis arrivé il était question de
supprimer l'église la
raser
pas difficulté avec aucune
difficulté est-ce que vous AZ quelquefis
des ennu avec les familles
oui ici on est
clérical et malheureusement moi mon père
était un libre
penseur du moment vous niez pas l'église
vous étiez bon à
rien mais alors comme je faisais mon
travail on jamais rien à dire vous
n'avez pas eu de difficulté non plus
avec le curé du tout il était d'ailleurs
très sympathique ce curé et est-ce que
vous avez eu également des disons des
désaccords avec les curés des visagama
je suis toujours très bien entendu avec
les prêtres moi il avait d'ailleurs un
nom bizarre pour la curée il s'appelait
monsieur
l'amourux et alors il était très
sympathique d'ailleurs quand il venait
me trouver c'était pour m'inviter àer
boire un coup dans sa
[Musique]
cave il était très très aimable jamais
il n'a abordé une question religieuse
avec moi jamais et au contraire dans le
petit pays où je suis allé à puse j'ai
pris la défense du prêtre parce que il
était très âgé il avait 86 ans mes
garçons qui était un supportable lui
avait fait des grasses de vilaines
choses et c'est moi qui ai pris la
défense moi qui ai donné la correction
en même temps j'ai fait la S morale et
le prêtre m'en a toujours été très
reconnaissant pour ses fondateurs
cependant Jul ferry Paul ber Ferdinand
Buisson l'instituteur laïque doit être
l'instrument d'une immense entreprise de
régénération morale Ferdinand Buisson
directeur de l'enseignement primaire
l'affirme le petit français forbé par
l'enseignement public sera un
missionnaire le missionnaire des idées
modernes
va petit missionnaire des idées modernes
petit élève de l'école primaire au
sortir de ton école montre à tes parents
tout ce que tu en rapportes tes livres
tes cahiers tes images redisleur les
récits les beaux trait d'histoire ou de
morale qu'on t'a
raconté et plus d'une fois peut-être il
arrivera qu'en te voyant le soir s
appliquer à ta
leçon ils échangeront un regard et
dissimulant le motion ils t'embrasseront
dans ce baiser qu'il te mettent au front
il y a plus de promesse pour la
République quen bien des victoires
électorales pour vous Madame Lenoir pour
le mot laïque c'est le mot laïque c'est
tout pour moi c'est vrai c'est élever
des enfants pour les faire apprendre
pour leur donner une bonne situation
pour leur inculquer
certaines certaines choses certaines
certains idéal et est-ce que vous
pourriez préciser justement cette idée
cet idéal que vous aviez lorsque vous
étiez une jeune
institutriceouz faire pour l'un
absolument comme pour l'autre qui ni
pauvre ni riche devant l'instruction que
tous doivent apprendre et que tous
peuvent s'élever grâce à l'instruction
que la République n don incarnation
l'esprit
républicain noir de la République comme
le nom pegy l'instituteur devient ainsi
à l'intérieur de chaque village un
puissant agent formation intellectuelle
et morale mais son influence ne peut
également manquer de s'étendre sur le
plan politique dans Lyonne même les
instituteurs ont activement contribué à
la victoire du Parti radical puis au
développement du Parti
socialiste monsieur Breuer ancien
responsable départemental du syndicat
national se souvient de ce temps et
pendant toute cette période je pense
qu'on peut considérer que les partis
politiques de gauche avait pour support
les instituteurs j'ai connu dans mon
enfance des campagnes électorales et je
me souviens de candidat inconnu dans le
département venant de Paris mais qui se
déplaçait d'école en école c'est-à-dire
de logement d'instituteur en logement
d'instituteur présenté par l'instituteur
qui le REC conduisait dans la commune d'
côté où iltait représenté à un autre
instituteur on peut dire que
pratiquement l'instituteur était
jusqu'en
1939 un excellent agent électoral et
d'ailleurs le syndicat était de création
récente il n'était pas un groupe de
pression efficace nétait pas ce qu'il
est maintenant et l'instituteur
attendait beaucoup des élections on lui
faisait des promesses d'ailleurs avant
les élections n'était pas toujours tenue
mais enfin il a vécu beaucoup de en cet
espoir de solution apporté par la voie
politique et à la suite des élections
tu cours à cette fond l'école faute
d'effectif suffisant va bientôt fermer
ses portes elle fut pourtant elle aussi
une école de la République et ils le
disent à leur tour et à leur façon ses
anciens élèves réunis autour de leur
souvenirs dans leur vieille salle de
classe c'est Marc
oui oui Marc oui pu C génard d'Es là a
béb colo
il y en a encore il y en a encore
làdedans qui sont vivants c'est déjà ça
ah oui oui et ben il les smirol je te
garantis Madeleine et je te garantis que
c'est
ben puis y a Rachel et puéa madame vous
vous souvenez des opinions de votre
instituteur C oh oui ça je sais qu'il
était socialiste à ce moment-là on
parlait pote communiste mais ça je sait
qu'il était socialiste le vre aussi
madame oh oui je crois parce que moi
j'allais au catéchisme régulièrement
j'étais en punition les jours de caté ah
en punition les jours de caté ça ça j'en
suis sûr il n'est fréquenté chez mes
parents je sais bien son
opinion et euh le vutre aussi madame
monsieur par moi j'ai des demoiselle que
des jeunes filles ce momentl mais on
était franchement pas rouge mais rosé
quoi vous comprenez alors non il nous
disait rien était pas méchante on pou
aller au catéchisme n'importe mais enfin
il préférait pas quoi et qu'est-ce que
vous voulez d'habitude enfin dans le
temps en entre en l'école on vous faisit
une demi-heure de d'instruction civique
oui aujourd'hui ça se fait plus du tout
du tout on vous apprenait tout de les
droits de l'homme et tout quoi on on
avait on avait un livre un cahier tout
mais aujourd'hui c'est ça ça y est mon
CAH on vous apprenez vraiment
l'institution de la République
aujourd'hui la République est fout et
vous avez l'impression que votre école
ça a été l'école de la République ah oui
oui vraiment ah oui mais depuis 40 quoi
ça été foutu qu mais avant 40 c'était
vraiment la
[Musique]
République
adrui les belles fontaines cependant
dans le rythme des jours et des travaux
dans l'ordonnance du paysage dans la
façade des maisons rien ne semble avoir
changé c'est du même pas que cautrefois
que les colliers d'aujourd'hui prend le
chemin de la
classe une classe semblable apparemment
à celle qu'ont connu ses parents et ses
grandsparents avec ses rangé de taable
noir et usé avec aussi son gros poil de
bois que chacun à tour de rôle à charge
d'entretenir une vraie classe de
campagne et qui évoque les ver de René
guigadou poète et fils d'instituteur
odeur des pluies de mon
enfance dernier soleil de la saison à 7
ans comme il faisait bon après
d'ennuyeuses vacances se retrouver dans
sa
maison la vieille classe de mon père
pleine de guêpes écrasé sentz l'encre le
bois la CRÉ et ces merveilleuses
poussières amassées par tout un été aant
charmant des brumes douces des gibiers
des longs vols d'oiseaux le vent souffle
sous le préau mais je tiens entre paues
et pouces une rouge pomme à
couteau
voilà alors qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous savez la critique ça se
compose des des qualités et des
défauts alors Jean je trouve que il y a
pas grand chose à dire parce que c'est
de mieux en mieux c'est mieux en mieuxou
par rapport à ce qu' a fait hier fait
hier Jour Dernier et
toi c'est entre bien et très bien entre
bien et très bien oui mais enfin encore
des
détail bon le texte il est
exactin vous avez trouvé desut de texte
non un défaut là sur le nombre de pieds
un qui n'a pas été prononcé monsieur N
enseigne dans cette classe depuis 21 ans
formé aux méthodes de la pédagogie
traditionnelle il a conservé à l'image
des instituteurs
d'autrefis le souci de l'exactitude et
celui des résultats moi je pense tu veux
dire monotone tu veux
dire
assez pas tellement
op marqu les articulations
oui je pense que la dernièrehe c'est
justement qu'il
[Musique]
faut la vieille leçon de récitation
n'est pas
morte les élèves
d'aujourd'hui sont toutis invités à
juger leur camarad et le magnétophone
permet d'assurer le
réflexion
de René gu cade odeur des pluis de mon
enfance dernier soleil de la saison à 7
ans comme il faisait bon après
d'ennueuses vacances se retrouver dans
saour il y a un progrès sur le sur la
dernière fois sur le début de l'année il
me semble que que Christine en
particulier appuyit trop sur un mot elle
s'est corrigé c'est très bien sur com
vous rappelez comment on entendait ce
comme bon ben c'est mieux cette
foir alors qu'est-ce que vous mettez
comme note sur
5 LZ la main est-ce que vous mettez
non pourquoi c'est très bien faut
utiliserch 0 à 5 c'est très bien ça vaut
j'en ai
4 les élèves de Monsieur néo utilisent
le
magnétophone il se livre à des enquêtes
mais le vieux cahier de morale est
toujours là alors moi j'ai transformer
ça si vous voulez dans ce que j'appelle
un cahier de morale actualité il y a pas
de rien n'est prévu à l'avance on trouve
toujours des sujets qui se rapportent
avec les saisons ou avec les événements
qui peuvent se produire ire autour de
nous au mois de septembre c'est le
moment de la chasse vous savez que je
suis chasseur alors je ne manque pas de
parler de la chasse parler de la chasse
on en parle peut-être en en vocabulaire
mais ce qui nous intéresse nous pour
l'instant c'est le côté moral par
exemple la chasse Estelle cruelle et
puis le chasseur prudent les enfants
cherchent les coupures de presse ou il y
a des accidents ce qu'il faut faire ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire en action de
chasse et cetera voilà par exemple une
leçon de morale qui est quelque chose à
mon sens tout au moins quelque chose de
vivant voyez alors toujours dans le fond
une partie dirigée premièrement voyez
que les titres sont les titres sont
toujours mis de la même façon j'insiste
beaucoup sur le côté préparation voyez
les enquêtes c'est pas quelque ça se
fait pas sur des sur des cahiers de
brouillon il faut quand même qu'il reste
quelque chose de solide alors voilà des
titres hein les oiseaux les oiseaux
migrateurs soyons propre voyez c'est
très simple propreté ég santé propreté
é= respect et cetera et puis il y a
beaucoup de de parties orales de
discussions puis toujours la partie
agréable pour l'élève de chercher des
des belles gravures d'avoir un beau
cahier ils sont très fiers de leur
cahier moi je crois qu'il y a quelque
chose de moyen entre le traditionnel et
les méthodes modernes il faut garder ce
qu'il avait de bon dans le traditionnel
et prendre ce qu'il y a de bon également
dans les méthodes modernes alors pour
revenir au traditionnel est-ce que vous
faites encore apprendre par cœur l'Étap
de multiplication mais je pense bien je
l'ai pendant premier trimestre on
reprend l'étape de multiplication il
faut absolument pas qu'on ait de
problème pour faire une opération
et ma fois ça c'est pas toujours
tellement agréable c'est pas tellement
pédagogique mais j'estime que c'est une
nécessité ça fait partie des mécanisme
comme la conjugaison
comme bien d'autres matières alors
allons-y 8 x
9 9 x
9 7 x
8 6 x 9
5 x
voilà alors je écris
contrôlez alors 72
54 et
40 attz ça y est VO 2 j' 5/ 5 allez
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas 5 5 au
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
7 à l'image encore des instituteurs
d'autrefois monsieur Nemo n'est pas dans
le village où il enseigne un simple
fonctionnaire de passage c'est à Drui
même parmi ses anciens élèves qu'il a
choisi de prendre sa retraite et le
faire construire sa
maison une enfance de petit campagnard
pauvre il a conservé le goût et le
besoin du Grand terre la chasse le soin
donné à ses ruches occupe le reste de
ses
loisirs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à l'image toujours des instituteurs
d'autrefois monsieur ne considè pas que
son métier s'arrête aux portes de sa
classe il anime une coopérative scolaire
il a organisé à dru un spectacle son et
lumière d'illeurs ça doit être un pe il
assure enfin les fonctions de secrétaire
de
mairie alors on verra ça ce soir avec le
conseil municipal micip tail enfin il y
a bien des petites choses de détail mais
n'importe comment ça ne va pas loin à
part le personnel puis là aussi quelques
travaux sur les bâtiments communaux les
sommes ne sont pas tellement en
augmentation pas tellement et nous
avions beaucoup à faire là oui oui oui
dans le fond on ne sentir pas trop mal
est-ce que l'instituteur
aujourd'hui a conservé le prestige qu'il
avait jadis C espèce de prestige sur une
population non non alors ça ça n'existe
plus on garde un certain prestige
suivant les rapports que l'on a avec la
population mais il est certain que
l'instituteur n'est plus le seul homme
instruit le seul homme informé autrefois
il n'y avait ni presse ni radio ni
télévision et l'instituteur était
l'homme qui savait tout faire qui
connaissait beaucoup de choses et qui
rendait d'immenses services ça c'est
terminé et puis le prestige la
diminution si vous voulez de son
prestige c'est également qu'il était le
seul maître quelquefois d'une ou deux
générations du village l'école primaire
était à cette époque la seule école de
90 % des Français et un instituteur qui
avait une certaine ancienneté dans son
village avait sans doute été le maître
de
des 3/4 de de la population et ça
c'était important et ça ça n'existe plus
il pouvait avoir une influence morale
politique sociale sur ces c'est certain
oui alors que maintenant il y en est
plus question vousmême est-ce que vous
avez cherché jamais à avoir une
influence sur les gens de quel ordre que
ce soit non alors c'est un principe chez
moi aussi bien au point de vue
politique d'autres point de vue de ne
pas vouloir extérioriser si vous voulez
mes mes convictions
personnelles l'instituteur se consacre
beaucoup plus depuis 1945 aux question
sociales qu'aux questions politiques il
est beaucoup plus facile de trouver des
gens pour
s'occuper d'œuvre social que de
s'occuper d'un parti pour s'occuper d'un
parti politique mais n'est-ce pas toute
la foi jadis si puissante dans le vieil
idéal laïque qui se trouve maintenant
etbran
certains mots ne semblent plus Guer
trouver d'éch parmi les normaliens et
les normaliennes
d'aujourd'hui et on nous a beaucoup
parlé d'idéal laïque est-ce que vous
croyez que ça correspond encore quelque
chose et qu'est-ce que vous mettez
derrière ce
mot ça vous dit quelque chose ça vous
dit plus rien
rien plus rien du
tout vous ne mettez aucune valeur
derrière d'idéal laïque et aucune
d'entre d'entre
vous un état d'esprit s'est modifié et
plus profondément c'est toute la société
dans laquelle s'insérait l'instituteur
d'autrefis qui se trouve actuellement
bouleversé
enuisé les jeunes quittent les villages
les retraités les résidences secondaires
les
remplacent beaucoup d'écoles rurales ont
aujourd'hui disparu de l'utre côté les
villages se vident
oui les villages se vident de leurs
habitants hein se vident de leur
forcément de leurs élèves et puis ça
nous amène la suppression de de beaucoup
d'écoles rurales est-ce que vous le
regrettez je le regrette profondément on
a déjà perdu le curé quelque foois le
bureau de poste on va perdre l'école
peut-être la mairie alors qu'est-ce qui
va rester le cimetière lui alors il est
florissant parce que les résidents
secondaire viennent s'y faire
enterrer et alors moi je pense qu'il y a
place donc pour des regroupement d'école
à la campagne puis il y a aussi place
pour de jeunes
[Musique]
instituteurs la foule des enfants se
bousculant à la sortie de la classe
c'est à la ville maintenant qu'il faut
la chercher les écoles nouvelles s'y
dressent signifiant l'avèement d'un
autre type d'instituteur et peut-être
d'un autre type
d'enseignement comment les normaliens et
les normaliennes aujourd'hui
conçoivent-il leur
méti le rôle de l'intituteur est
d'éveiller l'esprit critique de l'enfant
de l'amener
à être également capable d'apprendre par
lui-même c'est une ambiance je crois une
ambiance de classe qu'on essaie de
changer de rénover il y avait autrefois
le maître et les
élèves on essaie justement de de
concilier un petit peu tout le monde du
temps à faire de la discipline par
exemple les
punitions maintenant je crois que c'est
dépassé on en a besoin certaines fois
mais faudrait pas la meilleure
discipline c'est justement de d'arriver
à ne pas en faire see toute
seule je suis contre l'enfant la
lui-même mais je suis également contre
qu'on faisait un peu trop auparavant
savoir le maître qui apporait tout à
l'enfant
mais cet équilibre vous paraît difficile
à chercher oui très est-ce
qu'actuellement on a des idées très
précises sur la
question non recherche on a vu ce qu'il
fallait pas faire on sait pas encore
exactement ce qu'il faut faire alors on
recherche ensemble
et on
expériment CR climat moins sécurisant
que la 10 an quand Mme à Paris sur la
liberté marche ça ne marche pas en
général je crois que ça marche parce
qu'on leur fait confiance ça a beaucoup
d'importance pour les enfants la
confiance même si son petit le
sentent je
crois à ces questions certains de leurs
aînés ont déjà tenté de donner une
réponse à l'école d'éta la Sauvin non
loin de Druise les tables à la demande
même des enfant ont été disposés en arc
de
cercle c'est à l'initiative de chacun
qui est constamment fait appel la
vieille rédaction sur un thème imposé
est remplacé par une composition libre
l'inspiration individuelle s'exprime
avec spontanéité et parfois la poésie
jaillit fraîche tendre
inattendu la pie veut se marier c'est
pour rire et pour pleurer la pie
épousera le jet c'est pour rire et pour
s'amuser la pie est folle du jet c'est
pour rire et pour pleurer la pie est
folle du jet c'est pour rire et pour
chanter demain ils s'épouseront c'est
pour rire et pour pleurer demain ils
s'épouseront et le soir ils se battront
la pie aura des petits c'est pour rire
et pour pleurer
la p aura des petits c'est pour rire et
pour pépier la p et le GET les élèveront
c'est pour rire et pour pleurer la p et
le GET les élèveront c'est pour rire et
pour se fâcher le couple apprendra au
petit à voler c'est pour rire et pour
pleurer le couple apprendra au petits à
voler et à l'au les petits partiront
pour
toujours
[Musique]
après l'approbation sanctionné par un
vote de la classe tout
entière les textes considérés comme les
meilleurs sont imprimés dans le journal
de l'école galipette l'écolier se fait
typographe après s'être fait poète
narrateur monsieur hriot l'instituteur
n'est pas cependant infidèle à cette
préoccupation essentiel de rigueur à
l'égard de soi-même qui a toujours
dominé et guidé les efforts de ses
prédécesseurs est-ce que vous allez
aussi loin que certains de vos collègues
non je ne pense pas je garde quand même
un cadre de travail strict disons plus
strict que dans la classe l'idéal est le
même j'emprinte certaines techniques
aussi certaines techniques freinées
comme l'imprimerie mais je ne vais pas
aussi loin que certains qui laissent par
exemple pour le texte libre chacun fait
son texte libre quand il le désire et
cetera moi je ne vais pas jusque- là
chez les autres c'est pratiquement la
République des enfants non faut quand
même
pas il y en a quelques classes comme ça
mais enfin faut pas exagérer il y en a
combien est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est très répandu par exemple dans
Lyonne des classes comme des classes
République des enfants il y en a aucune
pratiquement il aucune non non mais des
classes plus avancées que moi il y en a
peut-être 15 ou 20 classes qui sont
beaucoup plus en pointe si vous voulez
au point de vue méthode que moi
c'estàdire au point de vue liberté au
point de vue
liberté liberté aussi bien en français
qu'en calcul par exemple moi en calcul
je gardde un cadre quand même assez
rigide alors que leur font faire
beaucoup plus de recherche les enfants
découvrent certaines choses travaillent
avec du matériel adapté alors que moi je
garde quand même un travail je suis des
livres si vous voulez et suis une
méthode beaucoup plus stricte est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que vous pourriez
aller beaucoup plus loin et que vous
irez beaucoup plus loin en ce qui vous
concerne euh j'ai peur d'aller plus loin
si vous voulez parce que je me ne sens
pas certain d'apporter aux enfants et de
faire apprendre aux enfants à former
leur esprit suffisamment ce qu'on
cherche c'est former l'esprit des
enfants et non plus acquérir des
connaissances et pour former cet esprit
il faut un cadre et quand on quitte ce
cadre la formation est peut-être
meilleure mais ça dépend de beaucoup de
la personne du maître il faut être à
l'aise j'espère que j'irai plus loin
mais pour le moment je ne peux guerre
aller plus loin pour le moment au risque
ensuite que les enfants fassent les
frais des découvertes que je pourrais
faire est-ce que vous rencontrez une
résistance de la part des parents oui il
y a une certaine résistance de la part
des parents mais en faisant des réunions
ass c'est souvent avec les parents en
leur montrant comment on travaille on
arrive quand même à une certaine
compréhension et dernièrement j'ai fait
une réunion justement où on je suis
arrivé à ce que il y ait des parents qui
soient pour les méthodes modernes et des
parents qui soient contre les méthodes
modernes et que ça soit l'opposition non
plus des parents face instituteur mais
des parents entre eux c'est des question
de génération des problèmes d'âge qui
jouaient aussi mais c'est une opposition
entre eux et non plus par rapport aux
enseignants l'école change et ce qui ne
change pas c'est l'enfance et ce sont
ses
visages l'image du maître d'école
restera toujours inséparable des images
de
l'enfance ces petits garçons et ces
petites filles qui chaque année se rela
devant lui leurs noms se confondront
dans sa
mémoire eux n'oublieront jamais l'école
de leur enfance j'avais d'excellents
souvenirs de mes années passées à
l'école primaire j'ai envie que ça
continue de l'autre côté de la l'autre
côté de la barrière
mais ais donner souvenir aux enfants qui
vont venir dans le fond si je suis
instituteur aujourd'hui je le dois
certainement à mon instituteur ilil y
a qu' d'il y a 45 ans à peu près et j'ai
été dirigé dans mes études par une
ancienne institutrice appelée madame
Lenoir qui était le dévouement en
personne et qui m'a guidé dans cette
pour l'école normale pour les pour les
études pour l'école normale et pour tout
c'était une véritable institutrice qui
était pour l'école laïque à fond qui
pensait plus que le temps qu'elle devait
donner pour attirer les élèves à l'école
et je vous assure que les parents n'ont
eu qu'à se féliciter elle a fait des
élèves vraiment ceux qui n'ont pas
continué les études et ben éta quand
même des des personnes valables vous
comprenez qui sont restés dans la vie
capables d'arriver à quelque chose
madame je vous lis la lettre d'une de
vos ancienes
élèves c'est une lettre qui date de
59 impossible de vous oublier bien chère
Mademoiselle saois S alors je reprends
impossible de vous oublier bien chère
mademoiselle sans soie de mon enfance
malgré mes 54 ans ma mémoire et mon cœur
vous sont restés fidèles il m'est resté
je ne sais comment miraculeusement
sauvegardé et conservé par moi un cahier
de votre cours complémentaire d'alors et
signé par vous j'y tiens beaucoup en le
feuilletant sous l'œil intéressé de mes
enfants je vous entends et je vous
revois encore mine rose yeux et cheveux
châtins simplement tordus en chignon
figure intelligente et bonne comme je
vous aimais alors vous remplacier pour
l'enfant d'assistance publique que
j'étais toute la famille absente avec
vous je n'étais plus
seul je vous revois en mête occasion la
main sur mon épaule tout en pour toutes
surveillant d'un clin d'œil mes
hésitations grammaticales et mes
étourderies vos récitations vos chants
ne sont pas oublié non plus le départ
des hondelles si sensible et nostalgique
mais rester intact vous étiez alors mon
rayon de
soleil digné madame Madame et Monsieur
Bourgouin can Alpe
maritime
regarde attention personne ne bouge
douceance cher pays de mon
[Applaudissements]
enfant
deendouci je t' gardé dans mon
[Musique]
cœur